no oh hey how's it going I wanted to do
a video today for once
some rare occasion you see I was trying
to get SDL to set up on sea lion and
found it to be way more complicated than
I thought
well
that's this let's just say I had a hard
time with it it's not actually that hard
well I'm gonna make the video that I
wished I would have found when I very
first started trying to install SDL 2
and have it ready for sea lion sea make
and amend GW compiler
yeah because it would have saved me like
three days of pain first of all you're
gonna need the good old sea lion and
yeah you can go get that and install it
on your own I'm not gonna walk you
through that part of it and if you're a
student you can get the you can get the
full version for free
I got sea lion I launched it here I'm
just gonna I guess it'll go through one
step at a time we'll do a new C++
executable we're gonna name it
I don't know Big Mama
see what just anything you know big
Mama's good it's better than just
project when you meet Big Momma that's
easier all right
hello world well first thing you notice
here is tool chains are not configured
configure okay we're going to setup the
tool chain with this compiler not the
visual studio one did you go to file
I think it's settings and then build
execution and deployment tool chains hit
the good old plus button and it looks
like it already finds mingw however it
doesn't seem to find it that well I
really have this install already
I mean look at my drive
so I'm just gonna reset it up with the
latest and greatest and I'll show you
that whole thing mingw I don't know if
people have like a way of saying it like
Ming WA Ming WA it's giving me what I
mean okay I guess I'm just gonna use the
Installer I didn't do this on my other
machine that I tested this with but it
should work about the same okay I think
i unsee that's great that's I mean you
can put it somewhere else if you want
but you don't have to look it has all
these extra options also support
graphical interface just me
all users okay we'll just leave all that
default that looks fine
decide to do is sing remember we're
gonna go for STL - we want to get STL
running that's simple directmedia layer
that's our goal this thing so we can
make make Adam games also gonna be using
a bit of the lazy foo code just to show
you kind of it running so big shout out
the lazy foo guy I mean this guy has
helped me tremendously and I'm sure a
lot of other people tremendous it's been
a tremendous great thing for coders
everywhere so it's just a tremendous
advancement for the interwebs and if you
could show him some support it'd be a
tremendous thing and I don't know why
I'm saying tremendous guess I'm trying
to mock Trump tremendous
[Music]
this is the installer thingy okay so I
marked them all no but update catalog
okay you yeah
okay let's let's do it this might take a
while so there might be a cut right
about the wood down low to hurry
uh-huh okay so that's finally done good
job next step now we can configure this
puppy and it's gonna try to auto do it
for us but we're just gonna say okay oh
it already found at sea okay so that's
where it installed looks like sea lion
just like notice it it's probably smart
enough to check there it looks good it's
got some check marks yeah I did this on
my other one too but it seemed to work
fine the whole detecting thing so let's
just give it a try let's see if we can
compile with that so a little basic
program with the sea I want to start
with stuff and as soon as we get a
chance we're gonna hit play and make
sure it compiles and runs and then after
that we're gonna add SDL two to it and
see if we can get a window to pop up and
you know get it basically started looks
like it finished okay
oh that was weird well just so you know
I'm not absolutely mad I'm gonna hit
this play button up here and we'll see
what happens scanning thank you hello
Big Mama we got it okay so the basic
compiler is working that's that's a big
step but now we want to add the SDL code
to it
I'm just gonna copy and paste some from
lazy foo so we're gonna include SDL H as
you can see it's all all read to the
side I don't know what Dad is I'll go
ahead and do standard IO as well because
he has some print def stuff we're gonna
declare our screen sizes this is just
the stuff from in that tutorial once it
once again whoa
it's one I want to drag it over here the
header bar disappears it's weird oh
there it is but yeah that's that's the
site if you want to follow along or
learn more well anyway you'll see that
okay so this is red it doesn't see it
sometimes you have to say in the SDL
folder and that does it but it doesn't
seem to be there so it didn't come with
it it's gonna say I are confused don't
know what this is so confused confused
so basically what we need to do is we
need to add the SDL stuff in let's go
ahead and do that let's just go ahead
and and get STL so that it finds it I'll
show you how to do that this is the part
that was stuck on for way too long
completed I actually didn't find a guide
that ultimately showed me how to do this
why I decided to make a video the way I
figured it out was trial and error I'm
gonna eliminate that whole trial and
error thing for you and you can give me
an upvote sound sound good it's nothing
good are you cool or are you cool
alright so we want STL now SDO has a
bunch different pieces but I'm just well
I just want to get the core piece
working to start just the basic SDL
library because there's also SDL mixer
STL fonts true type fonts STL image and
they're all this you do you do them all
the same way so I'm just gonna show you
the first one if you want to go get more
you can later
okay so you want to go to live STL org
click on the little download and we did
the mingw minghua take my [ __ ] so I'm
gonna click on that
it's a tar file so of course it's nice
and zipped up and we're going to
download it unzip it as soon as it opens
so yeah open that compressed thing and
here we go
so yeah you want these folders to like
pile into each other so if you drag it
in
it should dump into there yeah okay so
you got to be at the root and you want
to be in here so I'm just gonna go ahead
and do that with the rest all three at
once little pile in okay and now what
magically happens when we suddenly go
back to sea lion
it should upon a refresh start to notice
this now notice that folder was named
SDL to not SDL so i think we're gonna
have to put the two for it to find it
because it doesn't magically no but if
for example we went in and renamed stl
to two SDL SDL would be enough another
thing we can do if you don't want to
preface this with SDL too is you can
take all these and you can put them back
on this level but I'm not gonna do that
because I want to keep it nice and
concise in its own folder let's make
sure it actually compiles and it's okay
with that Oh God
when main 16 I think I think I had to
add the linker command okay
so you do have to go to your C make list
X the main one that's in the root of
your project now you have to add in all
the stuff that tells it you're using SDL
- otherwise the compiler will be like I
don't know how to link it I are not
smart enough now this here is super
handy I'm gonna go ahead and download it
so I'm gonna go to raw and hit ctrl s
and I'm gonna go ahead and save it I
guess to my downloads it's fine to start
don't do this show and folder there it
is I'm gonna do it cut
I want it to go here so we want to show
and explore the sea makefile paste it in
there and there it is so this file is oh
god you can't see it in that text my
cousin rap let's see if I open up the
Visual Studio code though kind of see
what it is basically it's a predefined
library that like checks everywhere SDL
could possibly be and includes it
correctly so it comes in handy it makes
it a little simpler you don't have to
use it but it makes a little simpler so
now with that said this find SDL 2
should work that's to reload to see our
see make changes
hit the play button
we're still we're mainly having this
wind of what is this air I forget I had
this on my other one too I fixed it and
I don't for the life of me remember what
it was I think it's just a linker what
we're going to figure it out try to
change the world with this video
[Music]
C++ programmers everywhere all right
we're gonna paste in more code and we're
gonna keep cringing ctrl alt or ctrl L
audio formats that's that's very nice
these
undefined reference okay so it doesn't
know where it doesn't know where all the
SDL stuff is is what it comes down to
this this should take care of it he
takes care of it on my other one why
doesn't take care of it on this one
let's just try everything in the book I
said you'd do all this stuff okay fine
fine well I didn't have to do that in my
other one that's exactly the same no
idea well that's how you do it good luck
have fun and don't be a programmer
unless I don't know you're masochist
peace out
[Music]
Oh